Okay.
So we were talking last time about rotation in ethane and the fact that there
was a barrier and that you can measure the barrier and one way to measure the
barrier,
the first way that the barrier was measured was remarkably enough by the heat
capacity of FAA and how much heat it takes to warm it to a certain temperature.
So that showed that the barrier was about three kilocalories per mole,
but it didn't say what the geometry of minimum energy was.
Was it eclipsed as shown by the,
by the red line here,
so that the eclipse form is the lowest and energy or was the favored form
staggered and people differed in their interpretation of that.
Uh,
ultimately there was some defractions study electron diffraction that showed
that it was staggered.
But now the best word on this nowadays is probably familly high quality
calculations.
And you can see from this paper published in the Journal of Chemical Physics in
2003 that there's pretty good agreement.
These,
all these various abbreviations or various really high quality computational
results.
You can see at the top our experimental results from heat capacity.
It's about a thousand wave numbers.
A wave number is 2.86 small calories,
not kilocalories per mole.
So there's heat capacity from infrared spectroscopy,
from microwave,
from Raman spectroscopy.
All these experiments give very close to 2.9 kilocalories per mole are about a
thousand wave numbers,
right?
Within a couple percent,
uh,
even less than that probably.
And then all these calculations give about 2.7 kilocalories per mole.
And it doesn't make very much difference.
The first one of these,
some of these aren't such very high quality calculations,
but some of them are very,
very high quality.
The best that can be done.
And they all agree pretty much.
So it's clear that the staggered form is favored over the eclipse despite what
everyone wrote in the 19th century when they always wrote them eclipse and what
whoever it was that drew the picture for the American Chemical Society of their
molecule the week last week.
Drew too.
He drew it eclipsed or she,
okay.
So anyhow,
but then there's the question why,
why is it that the staggered forum is lower in energy than the eclipsed?
Why is there a three kilo calorie barrier?
Well,
they're different points of view on that.
One is that the eclipsed form is unstable,
that for some reason having an eclipse makes it unstable.
The other one is the staggered form is unusually stable.
And w what?
What does this remind you of in terms of a question
compared to what?
What's unusual,
right?
This is what's unusual.
The eclipse for or the staggered form?
Well,
from the point of view of the eclipse for them,
why would it be unstable?
Well,
it could be that the hydrogens repel one another cause that just in space there,
there van der waals radio.
Okay.
But if you think about that,
then,
if you had a methyl in place of one of those hydrogens,
it's ever so much bigger.
Therefore you should have a much bigger barrier to rotation of a methyl group
in,
in propane.
But in fact,
the barrier is almost exactly the same.
3.4 not 10 or something like that.
So the size of hydrogen doesn't seem to be so very important.
Of course protons repel one another and the electrons that are in the bonds
repel one another.
There's electron repulsion.
So that might be why you don't want to have it,
uh,
eclipse that you want to rotate a little bit to make it staggered.
But that's not easy to do in your head because they're also attractions between
a proton on one side and the electron on the other and it's not clear which of
these is going to dominate.
So anyhow,
there's the possibility that it has to do with,
with,
uh,
with the eclipse form being unusually destabilized.
Right.
Because of repulsions.
That could be the other point of view is that the staggered forum is unusually
stable.
Now why could that be?
It's that you have a sigma on one side and a sigma star on the other side of the
ch bonds and vice versa as well.
And you can get overlap between this homo and Lumo in this way.
And it turns out surprisingly enough that the overlap is bigger when they're
auntie.
Then when they're eclipsed,
you might think intuitively that there'd be more overlap when they're on the
same side,
that when they're on the opposite,
but it doesn't take too much work to convince yourself that the other is in fact
true and that this is the better overlap.
So you'll get better homo Lumo interaction from one side to the other and not
only for these two hydrogens,
but for the other two pairs of hydrogens as well.
If the thing is,
is,
uh,
is staggered so that the opposite ones are parallel to one another.
Uh,
so you can get this kind of mixing Homo Lumo mixing,
but among sigma bonds,
which is called hyper conjugation conjugation is when normal double bonds,
p orbitals overlap from one to the other and you get resonance structure.
The name hyper conjugation was created to talk about the same phenomenon when
it's sigma bonds rather than Pi Bonds that are doing the trick and it's usually
much,
much less important.
We'll talk about more examples of this later on.
But at any rate,
that's a,
that's a very different point of view from the first one,
which is it that the eclipse does these stabilized or the staggered is unusually
stable or maybe both.
And in fact,
this is a little bit scholastic argument analogous to how many angels can dance
on the head of a pin.
And you get people that debate about this,
right?
So the point is that fundamentally there is quantum mechanics that controls
this,
but it doesn't say which,
which one of these things,
this is what,
it doesn't divide it that way.
So some people say one,
some people save the other and we'll just say maybe a little of both.
Okay.
Now here's a digression on the question of what's called Piseti,
which turns out to be relevant and a lot of biochemical applications.
So it's worth mentioning at this point,
this aspect of Stereo Chemistry,
Topa city,
uh,
relates to,
for example,
the question are two protons equivalent.
Now at first glance,
that sort of a stupid question.
Obviously a proton is a proton,
so they're equivalent.
But suppose one is the h of n o h group in ethanol and the other is an age of
the methyl group.
Now,
are they equivalent?
Well,
protons clearly still are equivalent.
Protons are protons.
What's different about them?
What's different is their environment,
right?
So it could be that the place they are is different,
even though the protons intrinsically are the same and therefore they could have
different properties.
Now that happens to be the case in ethanol.
And Ooh,
group has a pka of about 16 it's not very acidic,
but it's possible to dissociate h blessing Leibow minus,
right?
But an h it's on a methyl group,
doesn't do that.
It has a pka of about 50 so it's 10 to the 34th weaker as an acid than an
[inaudible].
Then the Oah group.
So there's clearly a difference between these two hydrogens because of the place
they're Ed,
right?
Uh,
so that the,
Ooh on the alcohol group exchanges readily with acidic water.
So you can put deuterium in and out of that,
wash it in,
wash it out.
And you can't do that in the case of methane.
So if deep plus can come in low Lumo attacked by the High Homo,
you get that and then unzip it the other way,
the electrons go back on h plus comes off.
So you can do this exchange.
That doesn't happen over on the other case because it's so hard to get the
proton off and the carbon has no unshared pair to pick up the new proton.
So these two protons,
the red one and the blue one,
the Oah and the methyl h are called Hetero topic.
Hetero means different.
And the Greek top means place.
So they're in a different place there.
They have different properties because they're in a different,
so tow piseti comes from the same root obviously.
And it means the placeness of the,
of a group.
It could be a hydrogen,
it could be another group,
two groups that appear to be the same but are in different places.
So this is a pretty obvious case,
but there are cases that are less obvious.
So protons within the Blue Group are homo topic and the green protons are homo
topic with one another right there in the same kind of place.
Uh,
at least they're in the same kind of place if we're discussing constitution,
what they're bonded to and what those things are bonded to and so on.
Right?
The nature and sequence of bonds are obviously the same between the two green or
among the three blue hydrogens.
And both of those are different from one another and from the red hydrogen.
Okay?
So the point of constitution,
the blue ones are home of topic.
The green ones are home with topic.
The redwood is its own right,
but the green is heterotopic with respect to the red or the blue and so on.
So that isn't telling you much that you wouldn't already have realized easily.
But if you get into stereo chemical to opacity,
it gets more subtle.
So let's look at Stereo topic relationships among these protons.
First,
we said that the blue ones were homo topic,
but are they really homo topic?
Let's consider those two hydrogens.
Do they have the same environment?
They're clearly the same with respect to constitution,
what they're linked to,
right?
But are they the same stereo chemically?
Are there environments super imposable exactly on one another?
Yes or no.
So are they stereo chemically homo topic?
Cory,
what do you say?
You say they are?
Can you,
if you take,
took the,
the,
the top hydrogen away and looked at everything else and then made another model
where you took the bottom on a way and looked at everything else.
Are those everything elses the places superimposable no,
they're not because one has,
one has a hydrogen down here missing and the other one has a hydrogen up.
They're missing.
You can't superimpose those unless you do a rotation.
Right.
So that's a question of con formation of rotation.
Okay.
So those are Daya Stereo topic from the point of that is different places from
the point of view of Khan formation,
but not from the point of view of,
of a constitution.
Right.
Sorry,
I'm getting right.
Sees confused.
It's a long run from the beginning of September.
We'll thanksgiving,
you'll find that this is this,
this will have been the longest period of unrelieved period of your time at
Yale.
It gets easier after this.
Okay.
So anyhow,
their dietary a topic from the point of view of confirmation,
but Hobo topic from the point of view of constitution.
How about those two?
Are they,
do they have the same environment,
those two hydrogens?
Kathy,
what do you say?
They're this.
They're Super Bozel.
That is if you took the h in front away,
you'd have a certain amount,
a bunch of stuff left.
That's its environment.
And if you took the ancient back away and looked at the rest of the stuff,
are those two remainders?
Absolutely identical.
Super imposable.
What is the,
what is the relationship between them?
Obviously I was sort of a leading question.
There are mirror images.
So what would you call those?
Two protons.
Not even anti omers.
It's,
they're places that are different.
He antio what in Antio topic.
So the ones at the top are in Antioch topic and the first ones we looked at were
Diastat area topic.
Right now,
do you care?
Is that gonna make a difference in chemistry?
Okay.
I say no.
And the reason I say no is that it rotates so fast around the single bond.
We talked about that last time,
10 to the 10th per second.
And when you rotate,
you exchange one,
one,
one takes the place of another.
Right.
So they exchange places among themselves faster than almost anything could
happen.
10 to the 10th per second.
So who cares?
Right.
So in truth there conformationally a stereo topic,
but you don't care about confirmation in this case because they would rotate so
quickly.
So they're going to have experimentally distinguishable properties probably,
unless you can look pretty quick
now.
So these distinctions are only confirmation on erased by rotation in 10 to the
minus 12 seconds.
I say here.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's more like it.
Okay.
Now how about the two green ones?
What's the relationship between them?
Pat,
what do you say?
What's the relationship
there in Antioch Topic Now?
Are they he Nancy or topic with respect to formation,
can you rotate one and give it exactly the same place as the other one?
Why not?
What would happen if you tried to rotate to put the blocks,
the back green one in the place of the front breed one,
change the location.
It would change the location of the,
Ooh,
right.
So how could you exchange their environments?
The only way you would have to break a bond and put the other hydrogen someplace
else.
So what's,
what kind of in Antioch topic are these,
is that
configuration
con formation or constitution that you have to change?
Can you do it just by rotation?
Is it just confirmation?
No.
Do you have to change what's bonded to what?
Didn't make one note.
So it's not con.
So it's configuration,
right?
But the important thing is you have to break a bond to change them,
So that's not going to happen easily.
So the difference between those two,
those are also eat Antia topic,
but configurational Lee in Anthea topic.
So that will last last that distinction in principle,
as long as the bonds and Dior.
So there's quite a difference.
Those two could be different.
Now let's see if we could see a case where there are different,
now that carbon is not a stereo genic center.
Why is it not as theory?
How do you recognize the Stereo Genic Center?
Nate,
you guys shouldn't sit next to each other.
I was talking to the other
candidate.
It's got 200 test has for different things.
Right.
And this has two are the same,
but it's called for this purpose of topicality city stuff,
Perot chiral that is,
it will become chiral if two of the things that are the same become different.
For example,
if one of them instead of an age where a deuterium,
then it would be a chiral center.
So that thing is called pro Kyle.
It would be chiral if the eaneandhea topic atoms or groups.
It could be chlorine or it could be methyl groups or whatever.
If they were made different somehow,
then it would be Tyrell.
Now,
so in ethanol that those two green groups are in Antia topic and
configurational.
So now tow pond in me,
that's names of places.
How do we name them?
So we have things,
we have groups that are constitutionally homo topic.
They have the same constitution that connected to the same things.
Okay,
so consider those,
the green hydrogen there,
the light green one in front.
And I'd draw the Newman projection also to show it.
We have to be able to give it a name so people will know what we're talking
about when we're,
if this turns out to be important for some reason.
Okay.
So the way we do it is to assign priority.
If the hydrogens were different,
right?
Then we'll be able to call it r or s,
Cause we already have a scheme for that.
But the two hydrogens would have to be different.
So let's look at the,
at the uh,
the priority Oah at that carbon.
The pro Tyrell carbon is obviously top and the methyl,
the carbon group attached to it as second,
but the two hydrogens come third and fourth.
But which one should be third in which one should be fourth?
Now here's the rule.
You give higher priority to the one that you're naming,
right?
So if we want to name this one,
we give it higher priority than this one.
So this one will be three and this one will be for,
so here's the,
here's the lowest priority.
You could run one to four in either direction,
high to low or low to high.
You get the same sense of hand is,
so let's think about this.
Here we have,
so if I put my left thumb coming out where this hydrogen is the bottom,
the number four and curl my fingers,
I go one,
two,
three.
Okay,
so this one would be lefthanded if it were higher priority.
Everybody with me on that.
So we'll call that not s we'll call that hydrogen pro ass because it will become
ass.
Okay?
If we,
if we make this for purposes of naming,
when we give it a higher priority,
okay,
now suppose we look at the other hydrogen that I've shown in the darker Arrow
here,
right?
It obviously is going to be pro our cause the same thing would run the opposite
direction.
Okay.
So Pearl are and pro s are the name that you can give to distinguished groups
that are eaten Antia topic.
Now is there a reactivity difference that we would care about between these
groups?
Suppose you bring up a chlorine atom and it can attack one or it can attack the
other.
So as suppose to the tax,
the one on the left,
right?
It's so mo mixes with one of the electrons of the h and the other electron on
the h goes on the carbon and we break the bond and a and get an hcl.
This is the first step.
Remember in free radical substitution,
uh,
or we could do it with the other one.
What's the relationship between those two pathways?
Can you see the pathway that happens on the left and a pathway that happens on
the right?
Are they the same?
Well,
they're not super imposable.
Okay,
so they're not precisely the same.
But what are the Sophie,
they're mirror images of one another.
Therefore they have the same energy.
So one will be just as remember we talked last time about how fast the reaction
goes.
Ha has to do with high and energy.
You have to go to along that path,
right?
And these are going to be the same.
So they'll have precisely the same rates.
So who cares?
Okay,
so attacked by a reagent like chlorine,
Adam,
those two versions of the attack are mirror images.
Thus they're identical in their rate.
So who cares?
But suppose
that you use something that's handed like a right hand to pull it off.
Okay.
Now suppose you use the same right hand to pull the other one off it.
Those aren't mirror images one another anymore,
right?
What do you call them?
What's the relationship between these two reactions?
What would you call the relationship between them?
Angela,
get here,
right there.
Dietary,
dietary,
married pads.
So there are different in energy.
So one will be faster than the other.
What does that tell you about the metabolism of ethanol?
If you got ethanol inside you,
there are things that pull the hydrogen off and make Aldehyde out of it.
In fact,
that's where the name Aldehyde comes from.
Aldehyde is an alcohol that's been d hydrogenated Aldehyde.
It's interesting,
isn't it?
But anyhow,
this can be,
uh,
would you,
would your body,
if your body was trying to metabolize ethanol,
could it distinguish between those two hydrogens?
Yes.
What would it be?
Why?
Who said yes I am?
Because whatever,
and assignments doing that,
it's going to be a 10 because the enzyme that does it as a hand,
a single hand,
right?
So it will be able to distinguish between those.
Now can we prove that?
Okay,
so a tax by a resolved chiral reagent like an enzyme.
Our dietary American should have different rates.
So horse liver,
alcohol dehydrogenase removes only the pro are hydrogen from ethanol.
It,
uh,
if,
pardon me,
if it removes only the pro our hydrogen in this Deutero ethanol,
it should remove the hydrogen and never deuterium in the case that it's
deuterated like this.
I messed that up saying it,
but you can read it better than I can.
Okay.
Now,
so that would be a great experiment.
If you had this compound s one Deutero ethanol and you reacted it with this
enzyme,
if you always pulled off the h and left Deutero acid Aldehyde,
that would show up with specific.
But if it works specific than you'd sometimes get one.
And sometimes the other companies often do you get different acid aldehyde
somewhat have deuterium and some wouldn't left behind.
Okay.
Now what's the problem in doing this experiment,
Zack?
How do you know that there's good tears right there?
How do you get the compound with the deuterium on only one side in the first
place.
So even do the experiment.
And this is where there's a clever way of doing it,
right?
That would be the reaction than you'd get.
Only the,
the deterioration left and never hydrogen laughed if it were specific.
So that's a good task.
But where do you get the starting material?
Now?
Actually,
the alcohol dehydrogenase is a catalyst,
right?
And a catalyst lowers the energy of the barrier you have to go through to go
across,
lowers the barrier.
But that means it lowers the barrier in either direction because you can go
either direction across this,
right?
So,
uh,
that means that you can,
this is an oxidation removing hydrogen as an oxidation,
but you could also do the reverse reaction or reduction.
That is,
you could start with this.
So what really does the oxidation lad is a catalyst.
What does is this Nad plus becoming Nadh,
taking h minus away,
right?
So if you ran this reaction backwards and started with a deuterium there,
then if the thing were specific,
you'd put hydrogen only there when you run it backwards.
If it's specific taking it off,
it'll be specific putting it on
right
now.
How would you know if it's specific putting it on?
How would you know if it did that?
Okay.
How would you know whether when it does this reaction it's scrambles and puts it
in both positions and then when you run it backwards it scrambles and takes it
off both positions.
Sometimes one,
sometimes the owner or whether it's specific going on in specific coming off,
Lucas,
you gotta pull it all begins Jace optical activity.
Ah,
if you could measure the optical activity of this stuff,
that would be a good way of doing it.
But it doesn't have very much optical activity.
If the only differences between deuterium and hydrogen,
not very much.
This is just kind of a gas,
but I mean if they did it to both things,
when you get one with both and then one with only one and then if you,
if it only went to one side,
you only do one with one second.
I think you said it,
probably not,
but I don't know that everyone understood what you said.
The idea is do both put on and then that product and take it off.
Again,
if it's specific going on and specific going off,
when you go through the whole cycle,
you'll get back where you started from.
But if it mixes up going on and coming off,
then sometimes it will put it on the wrong place.
Sometimes it will take it off the wrong place and when you come back,
sometimes you'll have h and sometimes you'll have d in that starting material,
right?
So you go both ways and see and that works right by starting with the same
catalyst,
an excess deuteride you do that to go that way.
Okay.
So if you do a full cycle like that,
then you come back,
pardon me,
come back exactly where you started.
But this proves the specificity.
It should,
but it doesn't say which one.
It doesn't say whether it was pro our progress for that you need to do other
kinds of experiments that we don't have time to talk about.
Okay.
So that's really a neat experiment that shows the Topa city makes a difference
and that enzymes descript discriminate between Stereo topic in Antioch topic
groups or Adams.
Okay.
Next subject is buyer strain theory,
which was proposed in 1885 so that's 10 years after van Tall.
Okay.
So here's the group in Munich in 1893 and here in the front and center is the
boss of the group od all fuck buyer.
And this picture hangs in the hallway out there.
The original picture,
you can look at it.
And the reason it does is that this guy here,
uh,
is Henry Lord Wheeler.
Did you ever see his name?
See how observant you are?
Lexi [inaudible] Pat?
Yeah.
When you come in,
there are these names carved on the walls,
which were the people who were in the 19th early 20th century professors.
So he was the first organic chemistry at Yay chemist at Yale.
And he went to Munich where a lot of people went to learn organic chemistry from
buyer by,
or remember was the guy who fiddled with the bread rolls together with a Fisher
to,
to make these models.
He was also the guy that did the,
did experiments on our snick and calculates kitchen when he was a student.
And so buyer was the leading organic chemist at the time.
Now in 1885,
he wrote that,
that's earlier than this picture.
That picture was 1893 when Henry Lord Wheeler was there,
he noticed that he died at,
uh,
at a 37,
the age of 37.
I don't know what he died of in 1911.
So he wasn't a professor very long.
Okay.
Uh,
so,
uh,
this paper,
eight years earlier was about Polyacetal lead compounds.
So a bunch of triple bonds arranged in a row.
We've talked about double bonds in a row.
You can have triple bonds in a row too,
but you don't have them for very long because as buyer reported in this paper,
they explode.
He had a collaborator named Doctor Homolka who he,
thanks for doing some of the experiments in this paper.
Dr Homolka does not appear in the 1893 picture.
I suspect that he just graduated and got his degree and went to be gainfully
employed someplace.
But who knows.
Anyhow,
Polyacetal things are explosive and this got buyer thinking,
why should I just a regular old hydrocarbon be explosive?
So he branched out in this paper and the very first topic was the theory of ring
closure and double and the double bond.
Now that seems a funny thing to talk about when you're talking about triple
bonds to talk about making rings and talk about double bonds.
But what he says is written closure,
which was a popular synthetic goal at that time to make new kinds of compounds
was to try to make rings.
They could make six membered rings,
they could make five membered rings in buyer's lab.
They actually made four membered rings and and three membered rings.
Right.
Although that was quite a chore.
Okay.
So written closure is apparently the only phenomenon that can supply information
about the arrangement of atoms in space.
This is 10 years after Vat off,
since a chain of five or six members could be closed easily while one of more or
fewer members is difficult or impossible.
Spacial factors are apparently involved.
And you know,
we already talked about a case like this where you tell something about
arrangement in space from the ability to form a ring.
You remember what that is?
Anybody
can hear routes and dismissive of the synthesis of Miss Siddeley formed a ring,
but that doesn't,
so he used that to say that where the methyl groups are on the ring and that
that,
that's actually a good example,
but it's not the one I was thinking about.
Okay.
Die Chloro probate,
is that what you said?
Uh,
it's not cycle appropriate that I had in mind,
although that was one of the compounds that we synthesize that buyer's lab for
the first time and found to be reactive.
But there was another occasion,
remember Malik and fumaric acid?
One was sis and one was trans and the one that was CIS could lose water to form
a rig.
Right?
So that was,
that was what he's referring to here.
Okay.
So then he goes on to say the previously,
so there's a website you can click on the,
see this,
the previously proposed general rules on the nature of carbon atoms are the
following one carbon is Tetra Vaillant who did that?
Yeah.
Right.
The four valence is or equivalent.
So shown by the fact that there's only one mono substitution product,
a methane.
We've talked about that three,
the valence is or equivalently arranged in space to the corners of a regular
tetrahedron.
And who says that carbon is tetrahedral van toff also,
incidentally,
there was a Frenchman who did it simultaneously called labelle.
Okay.
For the atoms or groups attached to the four valence says cannot exchange
places.
So you can't,
you have to break bonds to make new isomers.
Right.
So that if you get a one way they'll stay.
The evidence is that there are two tetra substitution products,
a,
B,
c,
d of methane,
so the van Hoffen labelle's rule.
Okay.
That you can have eat configurational enantiomers.
We would say
five carbon atoms can bond to one another with one,
two or three valence is that is you have single double,
triple bonds
six.
The compounds can form either open chains or rings.
That's what he's talking about here.
I should like to add the following to these generally accepted rules,
so these adding a new property to the models.
The same way van Hoff did van Hoff added arrangement in space to the models that
people already drew.
What buyer is adding is seven the four balances of the carbon atom point to the
directions connecting the center of the sphere to the corners of a tetrahedron.
That's what van Hoff also say already said,
but forming an angle of 109 degrees in 28 minutes with one another.
That's very quantitative and precise.
That's the angle between the center and two vertices in a geometric regular
tetrahedron.
Okay,
but then this is what's interesting.
The direction of attachment can undergo alteration.
It doesn't have to be exactly that angle,
but a strain is generated increasing with the size of the deflection.
So if you have an angle other than 109 degrees in 28 minutes,
then there's going to be higher energy associated with strain.
Or what he's actually talking about is not higher energy but reactivity.
Okay.
So he drew this picture showing how much the angles are distorted from 109 and a
half degrees.
So if you consider ethylene to be a two membered ring with two Ben Bonds,
the angle the bonds are going at is where it should be tetrahedral and in fact,
they're colinear.
That distortion of each bond is 54 and 54 degrees,
44 minutes and so on for three.
Four five is perfect,
right?
Only deviates by 44 minutes.
But uh,
the six member drink is stretched a little bit the other way it has to go out
rather than sharper.
Okay,
so he says dye methylene.
That's ethylene,
right?
The first one is indeed the weakest string,
which can be opened by Hbr,
bromine,
or even I had,
we talked about bromine or chlorine attacking the ethylene already.
Okay.
Uh,
tribe,
methylene cyclo propane is broken only by hydrogen bromide,
but not by bromine.
So it's not as reactive as the two membered ring.
Finally,
Tetra methylene and heck,
some ethylene are difficult or impossible to break.
They're pretty stable.
So this strain is causes reactivity if the bond angles aren't right.
So he's becoming more quantitative,
unusually quantitative for an organic chemist at this period,
remember the physical chemist,
this is just that the period when physical chemistry is coming into its own,
and they were the ones who did heat and energy and so on.
All buyers talking about is whether the things will react or not,
but he's using geometric precision.
Okay.
Now xoxo so the question is,
are a six membered rings?
I like this.
Cyclohexane they should be according to buyer.
A little bit strange,
right?
Because the angles should be the,
you'd think the angles would be 120 degrees instead of 109.
So they're opened up a little bit too much,
but Zoc see a young,
uh,
[inaudible] set that is essentially between a graduate student and a,
an a an a professor in 1890,
uh,
published a paper that had this very funny picture,
f up on the top there.
And people didn't understand what it was.
But what it is,
is a thing that if you trace it on cardboard and fold along the diagonals,
you'd get this blue thing,
right?
If you folded along the diagonals of paste the ends together,
And then if you,
if you paste Vantiff tetrahedral on it,
you get this thing and you'll see that this is just like this.
Everybody see that
it's using tech.
But this is a,
a base on which to build such a tetra heat set tetrahedral carbon so as to make
this structure.
And what's interesting about it is that these angles are the normal tetrahedral
angles,
right?
They're not strained,
Why are they not 120 degrees?
Because the ring isn't flat.
It's puckered.
Okay,
so that's what Zoc see said.
And he,
he gave people this thing so they could make their own models and see it right.
And he gave,
he gave,
uh,
the directions for building this more complicated base where you put it on and
have a different form of cyclohexane.
Okay.
And that one,
as you see it looks like this.
Okay.
So hold on.
So he,
in 1890,
he knew exactly the score that we would know that we would get with our own
models nowadays.
Now,
when this was abstracted in the journal that published abstracts of all chemical
literature so people could go there and find out what was going on in chemistry,
Yulia savago owner who abstracted it said,
it is not possible to write an abstract of this paper,
especially since the author's explanations are hardly understandable without
models.
Now,
one conclusion from that,
it should be therefore go and build his models and look at them and you'll see
what he's talking about.
But that's not what Wagner said and it's not what people did.
He said,
forget that it's nonsense,
right?
You can't understand it.
Okay.
So buyer wasn't happy with this disputing his,
his theory.
So he wrote in the same year 80,
90,
uh,
Xoxo wasn't too smart about this because he published that paper just as they
were having a big celebration of buyers,
uh,
contributions to aromatic chemistry in Berlin.
And there was this big fabulous dinner with,
you know,
18 courses or something like that.
All everybody comes from all over Germany gathered and Xoxo this.
Nobody publishes a paper and says buyers theory is wrong,
bad timing.
So by,
or published a response quickly,
he said a further proposal is that the Adams in Hexham,
methylene six ch two groups cyclohexane are arranged as in calculators model.
Now calculate his model,
remember by this time was in fact a tetrahedron,
which is what socksy showed how you could do it,
right?
But he says,
uh,
as in Calculus model and that the arrangement of the atoms in space is one with
minimum distortion to the valence directions.
That sounds like Xoxo.
But what he says is,
thus the six carbon atoms must lie on one plane.
It's gotta be plainer and six hydrogen atoms light in equidistant parallel
plane,
six above six below all the CHDS,
or just like this around the ring,
right?
Further,
each of the 12 hydrogen atoms supposed to have the same position relative to the
other 17 that is their homework topic.
You can rotate it if the plane is flat.
Now how can he say this?
It's not really like calculators model.
Okay.
The experimental test of the correctness of this assumption is relatively easy.
For example,
sufficient evidence is that there is a single isomer of hydro benzoic acid that
is only one cyclohexane carboxylic acid.
That is,
if you had this and put a coh group here or a coh group here,
what would be the relationship between those,
this place and this place?
What would you call the well,
are they homo topic?
Are they in Antio topic,
this place and this place?
[inaudible] Antique Mirror images.
No,
they're just different.
They're Daya Steria topic right now,
but you could do a neat trick.
So,
so that's what he says.
If it were like [inaudible],
then you'd have two isomers of Amano substituted.
Cyclohexane.
But what he didn't take into account was this,
this one is sticking up like that.
Watch this.
No notice the black one is sticking out down at an angle and the white one is
sticking straight up.
But watch this.
Now this one's down at an angle.
The black ones straight up.
Did I break any bonds?
What did I do?
I just rotated a bonds.
They're con formational,
conformationally Diastat area topic,
not configuration Lee.
So they,
they're different but they can inter convert easily.
Right?
So that's so buyer says he's right because there's only one ice mercy.
You have to regard it as flat even if it isn't.
Although he didn't say that.
Meanwhile,
as long as our knowledge in the field is so incomplete,
we must be satisfied that the above assumption is the most likely and no known
fact contradicts it.
Okay.
Now Zachs he didn't take this lying down either.
So he publishes a 41 page paper in the [inaudible] for Fizzy College.
It could be,
which is published by Austin Ball who hates buyer and vice versa.
The physical chemists of the organic chemists didn't get along.
So he publishes a paper and this other one where he gives all this trigonometry
to explain what he means by this structure.
Is this something calculated to appeal to organic chemists?
Not very likely.
Okay,
so this edited by Oswald,
who didn't even believe it,
Adams,
remember and wrote disparagingly of his successor in Riga,
who was,
had been an organic chemists scientifically.
He had been brought up in the narrow circle of contemporary organic chemistry.
And to him,
the arrangement in space of the atoms of organic compounds was the foremost of
all conceivable problems.
That wasn't what Oswald thought was the best problem.
So xoxo published again,
third,
nobody responded to that first one.
So we've published as a good in the next year,
34 pages again and here he gives more formulas.
Again,
things that didn't appeal at all to anybody who is actually interested in the
arrangement of atoms in space.
And then he died at the age of 31 in that year.
And that was the end of Xoxo and the end of his theory.
All right.
And buyer roads in 19 five so 12 years later,
xoxo disagreed with my opinion that larger rings are plainer.
He has certainly right from a mathematical point of view,
although I sort of doubt that by or went through every line to this to check it
right.
Yet in reality,
strangely enough,
my theory appears to be correct.
The reason is not clear.
Okay.
So that was,
remember Zachs it was 1890 so what important lessons should we take from the
tale of poor Xoxo?
Want me to give you that as a problem to think about over thanksgiving?
Fine.
Okay.
So this,
remember it's what Zoc see wrote and EAD role models like this.
And I just conclude the punchline here.
In 1913 brag and brag determined the diamond structure by x Ray de fraction of a
crystal and diamond,
right.
And in five years later,
Aaron's Tibor
published a diagram he drew of from that diamond structure.
Brags didn't draw the structure,
but more did five years later,
and here's what he drew.
And that is exactly what Xoxo men,
right?
So the arrangement of the carbons in a six membered ring in diamond is exactly
what Xoxo said,
but he got nothing for it.
Okay.
Have a good thanksgiving.